i am not an expert in the field but i  want to be seen as an expert that's why  you're scared the thing that everybody  wants can only be achieved when it's  earned you haven't done anything too  many people think fake it till you make  it is real even if they don't think of  it that way they think of it the nice  way the way you're doing but you're not  an expert but who is an expert and why  should you even try to be an expert i  never thought for one day that i was a  marketing expert or guru or genius i  just was executing every day and then  talking about what i was executing and  then they decided more than me you're  trying to get them to believe that in  you for your own self-interest but you  haven't done anything for them yet more  importantly why can't you just be an  enthusiast i think everyone is so  convinced that the money is an expertise  and i actually think it's in the  enthusiasm and i think just by changing  that word everything changes